it's Dawson ought to kick it away
that's fielded in the end zone
and a decision to come out is going to
cost him five yards
he's taken down white
a chance for us to look now at
interception the last time they were out
there ended up leading to a touchdown so
the only thing they didn't get really
with the pick-6
cuz that's what everyone wants take it
take it a meal to the endzone is
capitalized
he had no time to look downfield and set
himself to throw the ball and as he
tried to do that he was hit with force
to him confusion they go play action for
Jennings now man
direction and versus that zone
I've gotten to their spot gotten their
heads back around and they can see the
quarterback and everything
it's a big advantage of it
picked up a touchdown
so they throw the pig 6 don't get
another shot at it now as this one's in
the air
that'll be taken in the endzone
the storm
literally marker is down here there the
decision to bring it out no good one is
he's up a yard or two shy of the 34:20
thank you on first
way to Aslam
what you don't usually get a sack from
the nose tackle stock away
no we don't and a lot of times you can
pass the situations they end up off the
field anyway so how happy was a to work
his way back to the pier by completing
on the ground he kind of a bit of
nickname back to something like that
some big jelly or something
call it a gain of 13 yards on the play
and that's going to bring out the third
down almost not fair the big guy running
the corner route and he able to lean and
push and get to where he wants so how do
you stop it a lot of times you want to
have a line background I'm a bigger body
guy who can handle them physically but a
lot of times that doesn't work as well
because it's quick this happen hence the
route so they'll get a little extra time
to come up with this back now here in
Santa Clara it's the Giants with
possession of football but needing
points as we start quarter number four
these guys are going to take over
we always talk about possessions being
in a dream
on this situation during
you have to call your way
back in that one's going to hurt in a
big way and San Francisco gets set to go
here and that will s Drive a long drive
to Nanjing
starting backed up in their own
territory why would you change anything
and continue to do so because the
secondary they really look clueless and
that was amazing because that drive went
and no adjustments and no good
I was the target and it will be third
and 10
so a second down in completion now
brings up third down
Louis camper day
he's got his guys patent over the mill
they'll give him 80 on the plane and
that's going to make it fourth down so
much about offense is what you call
hidden yardage you know you throw the
ball to someone they catch it and then
they can make a big play
you know they create a play run after
catch they did a really nice job here of
limiting that and keeping them from a
first down now stopped him in his tracks
and with things looking pretty good on
the scoreboard they're going to keep the
offense out there and go for it here on
four
and the Giants are going to get the
I am NOT your partner there what the
mindset wise to go for I don't know some
teams just feel the possession is the
key to everything they just want to have
the football in their hands goes to the
other team they just don't trust doing
that
any passes in the middle of the field
anyone is getting after the football is
going to be conscious that is probably
going to be contested and physically
sometimes are these two draws
Oh
brought down after a good game a really
good pickup the 28 yards remember we
used to use the slash moniker to talk
about a player playing multiple
positions how about just slashing
through a defense unable to tackle this
guy one two three people bouncing off of
him
in curtain
people trying to tackle
what the Batman
got to pass he's got to have in a pass
he should have calm
man again in second down
so
focus and concentration and whenever I
see
well
they look like
I'm not sure you could actually draw a
that's Russian that one right there No
he had to keep backing up
backing up backing up eventually dropped
for a huge loss
and this one he's going to sling this
deep down
that is passes incentive
the football
I tell you about it
and so much applying defense
especially when guns are defending the
past is all about positioning and
technique and this is fantastic work on
both fronts there
offense now they worked their way back
onto the field and this offense last
time turned it over and forth didn't get
it
they're lucky though there's no points
against the team on the board but we'll
see how they respond
get a life credit they had their backs
on that last series and because they did
sorry that allows attention stay stay
aggressive and maybe go for beginning
makes it
the ball
come back to the line now
Kaepernick now and first
back in its own 6-yard line well many
times when you talk about mobile
quarterbacks you give the sense and they
feel like they can get out of any bad
situation they keep moving around and
trying to emulate guys like the
scrambler or the Dodger instead they
keep losing yardage and losing yardage
and digging themselves a hole that they
can't get out of
in that news Cabernet
this
taking down to the end zone for a safety
so make it back-to-back sacks in the
second one costume a couple of points
and the easy thing is to put this all on
the offensive line but maybe they need
to start changing their game planning
and their calls quicker passes running
plays especially when you're this deep
in your own territory parish now to
return
there's no downplaying
this was a critical possession and to
get a return like that to start things
off that's the spot that they need
that's the spark they were looking
New York said to take the field and
following the interception just any
interception or you'll get more cautious
when you start the next remember no you
just throw that out the window
New York back home 44 yards there the
Giants able to get this back within a
touchdown and there they got him the
ball just get it to him let him do the
rest you know he probably said that to
his quarterback as he broke the huddle I
like the play call just get it to me
I'll take care of the rest of it helping
out his ramp right RAC run after catch
and he loves that and he's going to
carry that in a contract time